we are delighted to bring you this
seminar presented by
labrutz welcome everyone thank you for
joining us
for today's keynote presentation titled
complexities of characterizing mineral
particle toxicity at the pulmonary
interface it's my pleasure to introduce
you to dr
christopher weiss toxicology liaison and
senior advisor
officer of the director of national
institutes of health
national institutes of environmental
health science
and national toxicology program
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the
tab at the top of your screen if you
have any questions that arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address those questions
following his presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain
those credits please join me now in
welcoming
dr christopher weiss i will now turn the
presentation over to him
welcome sir
and getting used to being ensconced
in our respective uh isolation
areas um i'm here at home
joining from the washington dc area and
i'm happy to be here
i am going to go ahead and start my
my presentation and i expect everyone
can see that now i hope
uh i've already had an introduction
we'll just skip through this slide this
is our facility
in north carolina actually i'm stationed
in the washington dc
area but we have a large laboratory
in the research triangle park area of
north carolina and that's a view of the
facility and another view
we uh are part of the national
institutes of health there are 27
institutes of health
you may have heard of the national
library of medicine
the national institute of allergy and
infectious disease work
uh and i uh that that institute is
getting
lots of uh attention right now as dr
anthony fauci uh is the director of that
institute and has been advising on the
coronavirus issues
uh you've if you've been watching the
news you've probably seen his face
uh he works in the same building that i
work in and uh we're here on the
bethesda campus
at in uh at nih
uh what i'd like to do with with you
today for you today
is to give you an overview of uh
uh an an incident that is both modern
and has been going on for decades it's a
forensic
problem that's quite complex there's
lots of controversy and disagreement
about it right now it's really a story
of corporate
uh greed really corporate the uh
the interest in uh businesses
making money and putting that those
interests sometimes
some businesses not all certainly
putting those interests
ahead of public health
so we're going to overview some of the
contemporary
debates and controversies and i invite
you to follow those they're
in the news regularly these days and
then i'm going
to not address those contemporary issues
specifically because i'm a little close
a little too closely involved in those
excuse me
but um i'm going to there's a there's a
similar incident that occurred almost 20
years ago now
that's strikingly uh uh
uh similar to the the incident that's
going on today and i'd like to share
that with you
uh and then um check back in on the
status of what's going on today with
with those same controversies so
you may have seen uh photographs like
this in the new york times
uh you there's an interesting article
in chemical watch just a couple of weeks
ago
that came out and chem watch uh has been
following this story quite closely in a
in a way that's
it's technical forensically technical
the new york times is discussing the
story
in light of various cosmetic products
that we know
are causing serious poisonings and
deaths
so i'm not again i'm not going to talk
in any specific detail about
that present controversy but we'll want
to walk through walk you through an
incident that
occurred almost 20 years ago that i was
very involved with
uh that's very very similar to what's
going on now
this is a map of montana obviously
and i'm going to talk about an area in
the far west northwest corner of montana
one of the most remote areas in the
lower
48 states excuse me
and uh it's about uh 100
miles west of glacier national park so
if you've ever
been to glacier park excuse me if you've
ever been to glacier park
uh you know how remote it is in in that
area of
our country uh
so once again um uh this is
this area the brown on the map here is
the panhandle of idaho and libby montana
is a little town of about 5 000 people
just a few miles south of the canadian
border and
a few miles east of the idaho
border it's a very
vibrant but but small village
here's a picture of libby montana it's a
beautiful beautiful area of the country
it's nestled in the kootenay valley
that's the kootenai river that you see
coursing through
libby montana excuse me i got a frog in
my throat here
um and uh there's a there's a movie if
you've ever seen a movie it's a
bit of an old movie now called the river
wild and that
movie will give you beautiful views of
the kootenai river
in this remote area of our country
the valley the kootenai valley and libby
montana's nestled in between the cabinet
mount cabinet mountains in
in almost in mid-summer it's far enough
north and they're tall enough to have
snow caps all year round
so in november of 1999
i was working to provide scientific
support for the federal government
forensic scientific support for major
incidents and disasters that occurred in
our in our country
and uh it was a an exciting and very
busy job
and and in in november just a few days
before thanksgiving in 1999
uh this article came out in the seattle
post intelligencer
and what it reported this uh this uh
reporter dr er andrew schneider
uh reported that in this small town of 5
000 people there were several hundred
former miners wives and children
that had been exposed and either died or
been diagnosed with fatal illness
in this small town so we were
immediately deployed
my my science team and an on-scene
coordinator
were immediately deployed to this area
to
help washington dc understand what was
going on
and so um this is a
this is a a picture of libby looking
down the main street of libby
it's i want i want you to notice the
inversion the clouds that are laying low
in there that
that's part of what cause problem that
i'm gonna describe to you over the next
over the next few minutes
so as part as initial part of our
investigation
we traveled to an area where we were
advised was the source of the problem
that was going on in libya and it was an
abandoned not an abandoned mine but a
mine that had been closed
just a couple of years earlier that was
about five to six miles outside of
outside of libby montana and this is a
picture that i took of that mine
on my first visit there just uh
probably a day before thanksgiving in
1999.
again you can see it's quite high in the
in the cabinet mountains
and it's been somewhat closed but still
lots of evidence of mining this is a
picture of that mine
when it was fully operational and the
way they mined was
a strip strip mining process where they
basically used dynamite and large
equipment
to make these terraces and and
tear uh a particular type of mineral
out of the out of the mountain and for
scale here
there's a i don't know if you can see it
on your screen but there's a
there's a very large piece of mining
equipment
way in the bottom of that pit gives you
an idea of how how big that
that hole is this was an area of the
mind that they called the glory hole
because it it produced the type of
material that they were
they were looking for in this mine so
this is what what they were looking for
this is the ore that they were pulling
out of the mine
and had i known what is holding in my
hand when i took this photograph
i never uh i never would have done it
uh this is the material that it turns
out
was uh just a deadly uh
exposure material to the to the people
in libby um what you're looking at here
is that is the dark in in the in the ore
that i'm holding in my hand
is a type of hydrobiotic uh it's a it's
a
silicatious mineral the white mineral
is a very fibrous type of uh
rock it's it breaks into small fibers
and
uh if it you know we initially expected
that
it would it was asbestos
so what the miners did from about
1960 about 1960-63
until the mid-90s was they would
strip mine this material out of the out
of the
mountain a mountain called zono light
mountain
and they would bring it to this mill
also on the mountain they would crush it
up with ball mills and uh various
means and they would blow air hot air
through it
through the material to remove that
white material
from the hydrobiotic that they were
really after
so what looks like smoke coming out of
this mill
is not really smoke but it's uh
the fibrous material that's been crushed
away from the rock
and is now um uh
being on the problem that they were
having
uh exacerbated by the types of
inversions that i showed you on the
previous slide was that the mine
and this picture was taken from where
that mill had been it had been torn down
by the time we got there in 1999
but uh this picture was taken from the
area where the mill had been
down into libby so you can see that
although libby's about five miles away
that material and that dust was making
its way into the air shed
throughout the kootenai valley
this is uh this is my friend les
gramstead
les passed away about six years ago
due to inhalation of the material that
we're going to talk over the next few
minutes and here les
has in in protest uh and
and begging for help and action has
put crosses for all his fame members his
co-workers and his neighbors who had
died
from uh exposure to to this material
and les promised me before he before he
passed away i got to know
not just last but many people in this
town after after working there
on on the case for almost two years
every every single week
les pro made me promise that i would
share his experience
and the experience of others uh with
with you
with anyone that i could find who would
listen to him
and so on the next slide we have a short
video it's about three and a half
minutes long
that i'd like to play to you and it
includes
les's perspective on his experience
it be montana as well as the experience
of several others
one of one of whom is was the manager
of the mine who you will see in in
legal deposition during this short clip
so
let's go ahead and play that
[Music]
my first experience there was what in
the
hell did i get myself into
i just couldn't believe that the dust
and
[Music]
the dirt
i went into the construction room
because that's where i was told to
report and he told me i was going to be
a sweeper and a dry mill and i had no
idea what he was talking about
but first you go over to the warehouse
and
get a respirator i had this respirator
on
in about 15 minutes i couldn't breathe
so i pulled this respirator off and it
was just
plugged solid i thought boy i'm not
getting nothing done and if i don't
i'm going to get canned so i just pulled
the respirator off and let it
dangle around my neck here and i and i
really went to work and
at noon i went back down to
eat lunch and i i was just covered with
this stuff
everywhere and uh tom de chazer was
sitting in there and he was the foreman
of the
of the construction department and he
said how do you like that
dust and i said jesus that's the worst i
ever seen i can't
i can't imagine anything like it
like it's the worst i ever seen and jeez
they all laughed you know and slapped
her leg and
said ah it's just a nuisance thus you'll
get used to it
the stuff was in your clothes it was
everywhere it was so
fine the only way you knew it is you
brought a cup of coffee
and you looked down and you could see it
settling in the top of your coffee
but you couldn't see it in the air but
you could see it sibling
in your coffee
[Music]
you couldn't get it often yet really
it's just stuck
the same way with the ore you know and
so i
took it home with me and
and i'd walk in the house you know then
my oldest daughter and my oldest son
they'd grab me by the legs you know
because they was happy to see me and
here coming to rita you know and
she'd come over you know and we'd have a
hug and
christ that was covered with this stuff
you know it wasn't that i was being
sloppy it was just that i couldn't get
it off
uh is it correct from that from 1948 on
you knew and the
company always knew that there was a
serious health problem because of a
large amount of dust
concentrated there
[Music]
it was certainly known that in some
areas there were large concentrations of
dust
and it's certainly common knowledge that
uh
too much dust of any kind is is
not a healthy situation
grace was on the school board grace was
on the hospital board
grace on the bank and when you talked
about
dust control here at anything about the
dust and
and what it was doing harmful to these
people here
the first thing come out of their mouth
was you you're going to close that mine
down and you're going to put all these
people out of work
you didn't have very many friends when
you start talking like that so
uh that video had a couple of things i
would like to share
share with you uh and point out
um the uh the the workers were obviously
talking about occupational exposures
that were occurring up on the mind but
there are also
tremendously high exposures lethal
exposures throughout the
valley the kootenai valley and
throughout the village of
uh of libya montana and
it's it continues to be a bit of a
problem uh
what they what they were mining what
they were after
as i mentioned was a type of hydro
biotite it's a silicatious mineral
that when uh that when you mine it it's
it's
flat and and looks like micah if you've
ever seen micah
and uh it it um
uh if you heat it to about 600 degrees
it pops like popcorn and so what you see
here is this expanded material
that is um is popcorn-like in nature
here's another couple of views of it it
was it was sorted into different sizes
and marketed for a wide variety of
products just a tremendously wide
variety of products and i'll show you
some of
what those were you may have seen this
material in in
potting soil see the white flakes in the
potting soil in the upper left
it's commonly used to ship
breakable containers particularly for
laboratory situations if you
if you're one of those folks that work
in a laboratory and you order solvents
it might come
in vermiculite so that's that's what
this looks like in packing material
it was also used particularly around the
processing facilities and i'll show you
that the material was actually shipped
from libby montana throughout the united
states to various processing
facilities that would expand it by
heating it and then market it it was
easier to ship and it's in its uh
unexpanded form so it was shipped all
over the country
and it was used uh especially it near
and around these processing plants as uh
as garden
material uh was used for playground
material
it was used for paving roads etc
this is a this is a photograph taken
from one of those
uh an abandoned processing facility
in minneapolis minnesota
so this the material that these children
are playing in
is waste material from the
expanding and processing of this ore
this
map shows areas where the large cir the
larger circles
are areas where the material was
actually shipped by train from libby
montana
to processing facilities throughout the
united states
the smaller the smaller circles are
areas where the material was
distributed so they're distributors
uh as i said you can still buy this
material in uh
large uh um big box stores such as
uh i won't name any specifically but any
of the large
garden stores etc us sell this material
there is an effort to keep it cleaner
than it than it was in libby
but mineralogists will tell you that
almost all vermiculite has this type of
fiber in it that we'll describe
it was also used shockingly
to insulate as many as 35 million homes
throughout the united states and canada
so this is what it looks like you may
you may want to peek in your attic and
see if you have this type of material in
your attic
uh if you do there are some some steps
you can take to
to eliminate your exposure or
at least reduce your exposure to the
material
this is an individual in colorado
springs colorado who
is now deceased but he and his son
had uh insulated their attic with this
material
in in one summer in colorado that was
the only exposure that they had was
uh just the insulation of their attic at
one time
and uh both both of those individuals
had passed away from lung disease
uh the material was also used to make
popcorn ceilings you see in the left
two panels on the left that
uh this material was used both
as an insulation and as an artful kind
of decoration in this large atrium you
see at the
lower left lower left panel during
during our investigation of course we
were looking into
various records and and paperwork that
that the company had
as part of our as part of the case we
were building
and we were um we learned during that
time
again this was probably about 2000
we learned that
the world trade center had been
insulated using this material as a
fireproofing on
the lower parts of both both both of the
buildings
and of course during our investigation
the world trade center was hit with uh
uh the terrorist attack and both of the
towers collapsed
uh this was horrific to us because we
we knew that not only was there a
tremendous amount of
other materials in those buildings but
they were also
aligned with this insulation
material that would have been spread
throughout
the the lower manhattan area
so again what you know what is this
stuff what we knew
that we had been told by the industry by
wr grace and wr grace scientists
and their contractors that this material
was not asbestos that there was no
asbestos that the mine had been closed
and there was no
no risk any longer because there was no
there was no no ongoing exposure we
wanted to look into that much more
deeply and we
initiated a a a large investigation
that included uh you know both records
investigation
exposure monitoring throughout the town
uh
and um uh you know
an effort to characterize this material
the problem that we were having
is that we knew that
uh regulated asbestos is is
only a very very small part of the
mineral fibers of elongate
mineral particles that cause exposure
and we
we suspected certainly that this was the
case in libby
we were told that the material on the
mine was
not a type of regulated asbestos
and here are the six types of regulated
vestis
asbestos this is still true today uh the
crystal
there are two types two main types a
serpentine
or snake-like asbestos called chrysoteal
this is about
makes up more than 90 of the asbestos
that was used in most products
throughout our country and um
there's an amphibole type of asbestos
this is made up of
many different forms of minerals and
uh i have uh there's five of them listed
here these are the only five
that are regulated and we we were we
suspected that some of these materials
the acanalite tremolite
might be present in libby but we had to
had to
prove that forensically so we initiated
a major
uh analytical and exposure science based
investigation
in libby montana that proceeded under
emergency response
authorities of the federal government
for the next two years from 99
on on into 2021
and you know we started by figuring
trying to determine the best way to trap
this material
we used asbestos cowls and look very
carefully at the difference between
cellulose fiber and nucleopore uh
material as a as a means to to trap them
the uh fibers that that were in the air
and we used uh we had
more than a dozen electron microscope
laboratories
on um on contract in order to help us
measure every aspect of the environment
in libby
so um what what this
uh series of uh micrographs show
is the uh
the this the flake in the upper
left-hand panel
is a flake of this hydrobiotic
and if you look at it at low
magnification so that upper left-hand
panel is just a 12 times magnification
uh through like a binocular microscope
you don't see much you don't see a whole
lot of fiber
if you move then um
in the direction of the arrow down to
the lower left panel
you begin to see small particulates and
what we're doing here is just zooming in
on that same
flake of hydrobiotic and then
so you you begin to see little
particulates if you go to
a scanning electron microscope at 2 000
times magnification you begin to clearly
see these thin needle-like structures
that are the elongate mineral particles
that we were interested in
and then if you go to 10 000
magnification in the lower right
you you see that these things are
are our mineral and they're
very long and thin
we use the electron microscope this
is a genie ore in her laboratory in
denver
one of the laboratories that we had
under contract electron microscopes most
electron microscopes have the ability
to shine a one micron
beam of high energy gamma radiation at a
particle
in the vue scope and in doing so
you get a spectrum like this because the
gamma
uh radiation excites the inner shell
electrons in the material you're
you're bombarding with that that gamma
beam
and when those electrons relax they give
off
a signal the frequency of the signal
along the x-axis
is an indication of the atom that you're
looking at and the
magnitude along the along the y-axis
is a measure of how much of that of
those atoms are present
so by doing so you can identify
fingerprints
of the minerals that are are that you're
looking at under the microscope so you
just target that beam
at a particular mineral and and take a
look at it so we did that for
thousands tens of thousands of samples
uh in libby they're still making such
measurements in libby today
20 years later but um we we did it often
enough to get a statistical
idea of the type of minerals we were
looking at and
sure enough the mineral that most of the
minerals that we were looking at were
not
were not
among the regulated asbestos minerals so
you see
across the top edenite and richterite
going down into the blue panel winchite
and
magnesio are benzonite none of these
minerals were part of the regulated
material we were we were concerned that
we would not be
able to regulate this material at all
using the existing laws on the on the
books
so um
let's get here
but what we did see is down in the lower
left that there was
the presence although not much of uh
tremolite and actinilite so we turned
to to that
return to using that information
to uh begin
uh uh
regulating and zoning in on charges that
that
we thought might be brought against wr
grays
and this slide shows uh
a bundle of these fibers we saw this
often
in the samples that we were collecting
this is a bundle of those fibers and you
can see that
they're they're they're clearly
associated with each other but stepping
on them
grinding them uh releasing them
would certainly cause a
these fibers to be spread out and move
into the environment
at the same time we were doing this the
industry
funded several researchers to
argue the opposite opposition that these
materials
were not asbestos at all
they were they did not have
characteristics of asbestos they had
characteristics of cleavage fragments
and
uh they argued that cleavage fragments
are technically
not asbestos and therefore we could not
regulate them
so this was this was problematic for us
we
we knew that whether they were cleavage
fragments or asbestos this was the
material that was
causing health problems in and deaths in
libby
and so it became uh an interesting and
protracted argument that
in fact continues today in order to
prove our case
we felt that we had to measure
uh health effects in the population so
as part of our investigation we built
uh medical facility a radiological
testing
facility and we we
recommended to the entire population of
libby that they be screened
through this radiology unit this is
basically a triple wide trailer
that you're looking at that we built in
libby in order to affect
a large epidemiological study there by
screening
voluntarily screening the participants
we did get 7
000 individuals both present
residents of libby and those who had
moved out of town
to join us this is dr brad black he was
the public health
physician at the time and here he is
inside the clinic and
uh showing you a radiographic of of
lungs of the one of the one of the
residents of libby
so this is the type of disease that we
were seeing in the population so the two
panels on the left are
microscope slides taken at autopsy
and you can see if you if you look
closely you see the
the mineral fiber the elongate mineral
particle
surrounded by cells that we'll we'll see
in a minute are macrophage cells and
both of those both of those slides on
the left
are microscope slides light microscope
slides
showing what are called mineral bodies
or
pharyngenous bodies they're called
pharyngenous bodies because they collect
uh iron-based stain when they're stained
on the right
you can see this individual with um
with pleural plaques bilateral
pleural plaques in in their lung those
plaques at autopsy
what we're looking at at the lower right
are
the the plaques on the lower on the on
the diaphragmatic
side of the lungs of an individual who
passed away from
uh exposure in in libby montana
again here are the here are the types of
disease that we're seeing this is a
high-resolution cat scan
showing this unusual type of disease
that we saw in livy
pleural thickening and i say it was
unusual plural thickening is not
uncommon but
the aggressiveness of this particular
disease was striking
and those little spots where the arrows
point are form
uh plaques beginning to form on this
individual's lung
they will grow rapidly and and
ultimately in case this individual's
lung
in such a way that they can no longer
breathe there are some enhanced
tools to look at this type of disease
this individual happens to have been
exposed to elongate mineral particles a
very similar problem to what we saw in
libby
but in this case these are uh folks
exposed to elongate mineral part
particles associated with uh tachynite
dust tachynite is a very low grade of
iron ore that's mined in the upper part
of minnesota and
michigan so the
the lung diseases that we were seeing
and
um are still seeing that are
related to exposure to elongate mineral
particles are pleural effusions
pleural plaques and diffuse pleural
thickening pulmonary fibrosis
malignant mesothelioma which is a
classic
disease very deadly cancer associated
with exposure to asbestos
and all kinds of bronchiogenic
carcinomas so
um these were we saw these diseases
all these diseases in libby and we began
arguing that in fact that there was
there was a problem here with exposure
to these
uh related asbestos-related elongate
mineral particles
regardless of what the uh industry had
been telling us
so um the department of justice agreed
with us
so on february 7 2005 years after we
were
uh involved in the libya case and had
won
a large civil suit against the um
the industry they the department of
justice filed criminal charges
so the several of the senior individuals
associated with the industry wr grace
were charged with fraud obstruction
of justice and and knowing endangerment
in in libby so this um
uh this
really was the culmination of a lot of
work done by the emergency response
group but i want to talk now
about the um you know what
what are these things and what is the
mechanism by which these elongate
mineral particles
are causing disease
and and right now the regulations are
based upon
characteristics that were very
useful years and years ago decades ago
when light micro
microscopes were the main tool used for
protecting people from asbestos that's
no longer the case
anymore we typically use scanning
electron micro
microscopes and transmission electron
microscopes for characterizing asbestos
so i want to take you on a little trip
into the lung to see what it what is it
how do these things cause disease and
what are some of the arguments that are
going on right
now in in as we continue to
try to protect the public health from
exposure to elongate mineral particles
so let's just take a little trip into
the lung here you can see
that one of the things about these
mineral particles
are that they can off they align with
the laminar flow as we inhale
and they can make their way very very
deep into the lungs
as uh as we breathe
uh so we're gonna go we're gonna go
we're gonna dive deeply into the lung
now so
this is these are the alveoli of the
lung where gas exchange takes place
and you can see that as as we know there
are
venules and arterioles that course
throughout this
lower part of the lung that there's also
lymphatic tissue
where the particles small particles
uh spherical particles that make their
way all the way to this part of the lung
can be uh removed and excreted in the
urine
so let's go into one of these alveolar
sacs
and take a look at what they what they
what they are this is a scanning
electron microscope of
of those grape-like structures the
alveolar
the alveolar sacs that where
air exchange takes place
uh this is a cartoon of one of those
sacks and i just want to point out here
a couple of things the um the alveolar
capillary membrane is just
0.2 microns thick so really we're
this is this is uh there's almost
nothing between
uh our blood our bloodstream in the lung
and these uh uh
and and the air that comes into these
alveolar sacs
the other thing i want to point out in
the lower right is
the alveolar macrophage and i want to
talk to you a little bit about that
and the role that it plays in this type
of disease
so this is a scanning electron micro
micrograph
of an alveolar macrophage and this is
one of the things i love about biology
because it's just fascinating what these
these cells do there are trillions of
them throughout our body and and um
and of course throughout the lung where
they where they scavenge they move
they uh have an amoeba-like movement
they move throughout the uh the lung
they
identify using these pseudopods the
strings that look like they're coming
out of that cell
are actually pseudopods and if you look
closely you can see little sensory
ends on those pseudopods in this case
the macrophage
is looking for and identifying bacteria
it will take those bacteria into itself
and digest those
using various types of lysosomal
activities and
these cells also identify aging
red blood cells which you see a red
blood cell up
up to the right and the macrophages is
uh
identifying that as a potential um
uh if if that blood cell is aberrant in
any way or it's aging that
it will be recycled the components of it
will be saved and other parts excreted
in the urine
so what happens if we look at the
left-hand side of this
is the macrophage uh and this is
obviously a cartoon
of a mac uh macrophage you see the
elongate
mineral particles in the upper left uh
they're being
invaginated and taken into the
macrophage cell where they activate
a number of systems cell signaling
systems
and the release of cytokines that are
associated with
inflammation so this is you know it's a
complex system that we won't go into
any great detail on now but collectively
this process is referred to as the
inflammasome and and so this macrophage
the inflammasome is being activated by
these elongated mineral particles and
it's excreting an interleukin
a type of cytokine interleukin-1 beta
so one of the things that we have done
at nih is look
because we have the ability now using
nanotechnology
to to manufacture uh
elongate mineral particles of various
sizes and
shapes and and um and makeup
and what we're what we were interested
here in this experiment is looking at
the relationship between the aspect
ratio which is ar
over in the graph on the right ar is
it so these these particles are very
uniform they all have an aspect ratio of
six to one
and then at the bottom of the graph you
see uh
an a lesser aspect ratio the message
being here that the large
the larger the aspect ratio
the greater that the uh
inflammasome is activated and what's
interesting about this
experiment is up in the right you can
see that
particles even less than two microns in
length
cause this type of inflammasome
activation
and we think that's very very important
with respect to the present
definitions of regulatory asbestos
so so this is another picture of a
macrophage
and in this case the macrophage has
tried to engulf
elongate mineral particles and it's
become frustrated with that process
so it is it is creating what uh
a um a cytochrome cytochrome storm if
you will
and um so uh
the next step in this process would be
for this macropage to recruit other
macrophages and begin
scarring off these these elongate
mineral particles
so that is really what is the initiation
of the plaque formation
formation that i showed you on the
previous slide
again these these particles break down
they break down in the environment
these these bundle these bundles of
fibers
break down in the environment they also
interestingly and this is work done by
dr phil
cook at epa's laboratory in duluth
duluth minnesota
what phil cook did was he dosed animals
with
with bundles of various types of
asbestos
and monitored them over the course of of
two years so
what we see here is that on the on the
y-axis
the number of elongate mineral particles
actually went up in the lung over the
course of those two years so he gave
one dose and that dose
actually grew of course across
the course of those two years so we
think this has a lot to do with why
asbestos has it has a latency period of
years in some cases
because bundles are splitting into
smaller and smaller
uh sizes and uh they're
continuing to cause this uh inflamma
inflammatory reaction in the lung
presently um and this this
is a graph uh cumulative frequency
distribution of the sizes of particles
that we collected
in libby montana and what we knew after
the early stages of our investigation
was that
most of the particles that we were
seeing were less than 5 microns
the red line through this graph
indicates
epa's regulatory limit so epa regulates
everything to the right
but doesn't but does not regulate
anything
to the left based upon the length of the
elongate mineral particle we think this
is problematic
because uh as i showed you on the on the
pre a couple of slides back even fibers
as short as two microns can
activate the inflamma cell
so that brings us um let's see how our
time's doing here that brings
us close to the to the end of my
presentation but i wanted to remind you
that in fact these arguments are
raging right now i know we're all busy
of course with
the coronavirus issues and covet 19.
but as as we as we deal with this
the discussions and and
debates uh and science regarding
exposure to these elongate mineral
particles is raging
largely in part due to
exposure to cosmetic products that have
these
so-called unregulated particles
in them uh and uh as you can see baby
powder
is is highlighted here baby johnson
johnson baby powder is not the only
product that where
that's problematic but uh it's probably
one of the most controversial right now
so let's see here
so um within the last
several months fda has become interested
in this
in this issue as well and these
graphs are public now so i can show show
you them but
what we see here is the same phenomena
where
in fact most of the particles these
taken from various
cosmetic products very recently
have these elongate mineral particles
that are shorter than
the regulated limit again the regulated
uh limit is five microns if you look at
the x-axis
most of the particles in in these
samples that are being pulled
are shorter than the regulatory limit
yet we know from history
and from toxicology and from the
information that i just showed you that
these
that these uh short particles can indeed
cause
uh disease and and death
so we're we're debating that right now
in the in the forensic and um
toxicological arenas
this this study um was done by niosh
a few years ago and it it highlights the
same concept
so what was done here is dr les staner
went back to old epidemiological studies
and pulled the light microscopic slides
from many studies and
measured them using an electron
microscope his objective here is to look
and see
what the relationship between the
shorter particles
and the regulated particles were and
you can read his conclusions here but
what you see
and again this red line depicts um
everything that is in fact regulated all
of that being you know toward you
toward the viewer so the the um
the white topped bars are regulated
but again most of the material in these
uh in these studies in these
epidemiological studies that had been
originally
measured with light microscopy when they
were looked at with electron microscopy
they dominated the exposure and um
this is this is this is a problem so um
i think that might be
my last slide yeah there it is so i'm
happy to
answer any questions or or try to do
that if i can
and thank you dr weiss for that
outstanding presentation
and we will now move to the q a portion
of this presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions in the q a box and any pres
questions we cannot answer today we will
answer them via email so let's take a
look
at our questions coming in from our
audience members and we have
time for just a few today our first
question dr weiss
is what was the primary symptoms
that appeared in the exposure
so um what
what we saw in in libby montana
was we we knew there were cases of lung
cancer and mesothelioma
but far and away most of the disease
that we saw
were plural plural plaques plural plural
plaquing
and when we engaged the industry on this
topic
and and we knew that this plural
plaquing would progress to lethal
disease if it was allowed to
to proceed and and there's really no
treatment for it so once the plaquing
initiative was initiated
it it typically continued to a
debilitating or lethal
uh disease um uh
you know what we saw was far and away
most of this material
what most of the disease was related to
this pleural plaquing
and not mesothelioma or lung cancer
thank you for that and were they aware
that the dust in the air
was asbestos at the time
there was discussion about that but uh
the industry you know as you saw from
the video
the industry dominated the the town
they owned they they donated all the
money to the
the high school to to keep the school
going
interestingly they had spread
vermiculite contaminated vermiculite all
over the track
and the the track coach died of
mesothelioma
uh they uh supported the churches they
said they
they for all practical purposes owned
the hospital uh uh there were there was
some evidence that
they they had such dominant dominant
influence over the hospital that
diagnoses were changed and that sort of
thing
but um
they're the the
um the town was essentially owned by
the the industry and so there were
rumors of asbestos
being present but they had effectively
convinced not just the population but
the regulatory authorities that this was
not
asbestos that it was cleavage fragments
and
uh and they fell outside of the
regulatory range
thank you for that and what is the
difference between
asbestos and cleavage product
well that's the debate that's going on
right now
in in i'm not a mineralogist
but asbestos uh my my understanding
is that asbestos is uh
born of of a uh
of a process of a geologic process that
pulls the rock somewhat like taffy
it uh it stretches the rock it becomes
very high in
in tensile strength etc cleavage
fragments by contrast
are chips or crystals that break
off of larger pieces of rock that are of
the same mineral nature so if you have
let's say you have a rock of tremolite
you can have
tremolite that has in fact grown
geologically grown
over millions of years as as an asbesto
form
type but you can also
have weaknesses in the crystal structure
that cause
long thin elongate mineral particles and
that's why i use that term
to um to form and and the argument
between industry and the regulators
right now is that cleavage fragments are
not
true asbestos and therefore they cannot
be regulated and that's the case still
in our country
and that's why um uh products
uh you know such as those that i showed
are still
allowed on the market despite the fact
that we know they're causing
disease we know how the disease is
caused by
this inflammatory reaction etc it's
uh it's it's a very interesting forensic
problem
interesting to me because i've been
working on it for more than 20 years
and i'm still working on it it's still
an argument in
in the in the regulatory arena
we have time for one more question and
here's an interesting one
does pay does baby powder contain
these elongated mineral products
yes
short and sweet huh thank you dr weiss
and thank you for this outstanding
presentation once again for your
important research
do you have any closing remarks for our
audience as we close today
no i i but i would like to just thank
uh um the lab lab roots and
especially uh thanks to to tyler uh
and lynn and susie you for for guiding
me through this i
apologize for the little glitch that we
had there uh this uh
virtual world is new to all of us so i'm
i'm gonna take a pass on that
and thanks to everyone who joined joined
today i hope you
you um i hope it was instructive and
interesting to you and i'm glad to try
and answer any questions if i can
uh answer your emails
yes definitely and thank you again dr
weiss
um for your presentation and as a final
reminder to our audience members any
questions that were submitted
that were not answered today will be
answered via email
by dr weiss this presentation will be
available
for on-demand viewing until november
2020 so please share it with your
colleagues who may have missed
today's topic thank you again for your
participation
until next time take care and stay
healthy
bye bye